Northwest is a girl of many talents and
now you can add tick tock star to the
list yep Kim Kardashian and Kanye West
adorable daughter recently joined her
pal Kaden Mills for a little fun on
tick-tock
in the first video Kaden picks up
Northey before they ham it up for the
camera
[Music]
still pop into the same track they flex
their skills again for a second video
[Music]
truly this is the tic-tock duo we didn't
know we needed but north isn't the only
member of the famous fams show it off on
social media her cousin Courtney's
daughter Penelope Disick has got some
sweet skills of her own yep Penelope is
quite the gymnast unfortunately we can't
exactly say the same for auntie Chloe or
grandma Kris Jenner between North and
Penelope there's no doubt the next
generation of Kardashian kids will take
over no matter what careers they choose
in fact Kim told et in 2018 she's
totally down for little Northey taking
over her beauty empire someday she
definitely loves makeup if she loves it
enough she can definitely take it over
whatever she wants to do when she is old
enough she can do but her new favorite
thing ever is no one in the room no
adults closing the door with one of her
friends or her dolls and doing makeovers
and no one can see until the final look
is done or she'll freak out and cry and
you know North loves a before-and-after
she loves it before and after
you